in Leipzig muss dieser marode Steg über
die nahle ersetzt werden eine schöne
neue Brücke soll her 4 Meter breit oder
doch lieber fünf diese Frage sorgt im
Stadtrat für endlose Debatten das Hin
und Her führt dazu dass der Neubau schon
jetzt 2,2 Millionen Euro teurer wird
ohne dass überhaupt ein Spatenstich
gemacht wurde
das ist für mich unfassbar dass wir es
immer wieder schaffen Geld zu
verschwenden weil wir nicht in der Lage
sind Zeiten eine Entscheidung zu treffen
das ist furchtbar wenn ich ehrlich bin
das ist bescheuert mehr fällt mir da
nicht ein ganz ehrlich das der Name
steht ganz dringend erneuert werden muss
steht seit Jahren fest er wird nur noch
notdürftig mit Eisen Klemmen
zusammengehalten im Januar 2022 stellt
die Stadt Leipzig ihre fertige Planung
im Stadtrat vor der Steg soll vier Meter
breit werden und drei Millionen Euro
kosten aber der Stadtrat lehnt in
Entwurf ab will eine Breite von 5 Metern
mehr Platz für Fußgänger und Radfahrer
alles wird gestoppt das Ding muss völlig
neu geplant werden dann stellt man fest
fünf Meter sind Blödsinn denn der Weg
zur Brücke ist sehr viel schmaler und
absolut ausreichend also alles auf
Anfang der Steg soll wie ursprünglich
geplant neu gebaut werden kostet jetzt
aber wegen enorm gestiegener Baukosten
mindestens 5,2 Millionen Euro
anstatt einfach zu sagen Thema macht sie
jetzt vier Meter reicht doch und warum
muss man sich da streiten einfach bauen
das ist diese schlimme deutsche
Bürokratie das alles so eine Projekte
dann dauernd teurer werden im Leipziger
Rathaus ärgert man sich über das teure
städtische planungschaos am Ende sind
Steuergelder aus welchem Topf ist kommt
es kann man diskutieren aber ein
Steuergeld bleibt Steuergeld und die
Leute die Steuern zahlen die reiben sich
natürlich die Augen kann ich verstehen
und hätte man hier einmal inne gehalten
im Stadtrat einmal länger diskutiert
noch mal sich vier Wochen Zeit genommen
hätte man vermeiden können
in Leipzig haben die Menschen kein
Verständnis für das kostspielige hin und
her
diese 2,2 Millionen Euro die jetzt das
mehr kostet für andere Dinge viel besser
hätten investiert werden können und das
ist ehrlich gesagt sehr schade und
traurig weil wir Weltmeister im
diskutieren sind das niemand da der sagt
so wird's gemacht eigentlich sollte das
Steg nun schon fast fertig sein jetzt
soll die neue Brücke Ende nächsten
Jahres eröffnet werden wenn in Leipzig
nicht wieder was dazwischen kommt